Now, let's get familiar with some of
the abstractions provided by an operating system. I'm
sure that you may have heard several different
terms used in the context of an operating
system such as program or a process or a thread and task and so on. Let's
understand these terms. A program is the memory
footprint that is created when you click on
an icon to launch an application on your favorite platform. So it is a static
image of the program loaded into the memory. A process, on the other
hand, is a program in execution. That is, the operating system, breathes life
into the program, which is a static entity, by running the program on the CPU.
That is, by scheduling the program to run on the processor, the operating system
gives life to the program and the
process is the program in execution. Therefore a
process is the program plus the state of the running program. And yes, the state
of the running program is not static.
It is continuously evolving as the program executes.
So these are the two important abstractions related to the process and program.
Which is a static entity created by the operating system when
you launch a program. And process is the program in execution.